parce que nos villes se transformment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
iprema votre partenaire pour un
développement
durable bonjour à T et bienvenue dans
équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement et on commence tout de
suite par le sommaire de votre émission
une rencontre débat sur l'évolution des
espèces se tenait à la Maison de
l'Environnement de maniléamo l'occasion
d'en apprendre un peu plus sur l'origine
et le devenir des espèces animales et
végétal rendez-vous ensuite à Villette à
la rencontre d'Emmanuel Coupin
pisiculteur respectueux de
l'environnement et seul aquaculteur
durable
d'île-de-fance mais pour commencer nous
abordons ce mois-ci le thème de la
biodiversité déforestation écosystèmes
menacés et espèces en voie de
disparition aujourd'hui notre
biodiversité est en
danger pour en parler nous partons à la
rencontre de Jean-François Sylvain
chercheur à l'Institut de recherche pour
le développement du CNRS de Gif
surivette c'est parti
suivez-moi Jean-François Sylvain bonjour
bonjour merci de nous recevoir ici au
CNRS à GIV survette on parle
biodiversité déjà une petite
présentation de de la biodiversité
à quel différents niveaux se
décline-t-elle cette
biodiversité la biodiversité en fait
c'est
l'ensemble les formes de vie qu'on va
trouver sur la planète alors planète
c'est les terres émergées mais c'est
aussi bien entendu les océan et cetera
alors forme de vie ben c'est des
populations c'est des espèces avant
c'est même des gènes hein et puis ce qui
est important c'est aussi toutes les
interactions entre ces espècesin les
espèces ne vivent pas de manière isolée
hein elles vivent en interaction les
unes avec les autres au sein des
écosystèmes aujourd'hui Jean-François
qu'est-ce qui menace cette biodiversité
alors les menaces bon on a toujours en
tête les les les les grandes menaces
classiques alors il y a le changement
climatique même s'il n'est pas toujours
facile de voir quel seront les
conséquences du changement climatique
sur la biodiversité comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure dans ses différentes
facettes
après il y a ce qu'on appelle le
changement d'usage des terres alors on
est tout même sur une planète où on va
atteindre tôt ou tard 11 milliards
d'habitants à peu près donc une pression
énorme pour transformer les terres
peuentropisé en terre agricole par
exemple hein l'urbanisation qui est
considérable alors moins chez nous là
aussi qu'au sud où on voit se créer des
mégapoles énormes donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle le changement d'age des terre
qui transforme des milieux semi-naturels
peu antropisés en milieu fortement
antropisés donc ça c'est après il y a ce
qu'on appelle la surexploitation des
ressources la pêche est qu même un des
grands exemples actuels où il y a des
éléments de surexploitation de certaines
ressources qui ont pu amener à la
disparition de certaines ressources
dites aliotique avec des conséquences
graves à la fois pour les pêcheurs mais
en même temps pour les populations qui
consomment ces ces ressources quel
changement et pertes irréparables
entraînent ces phénomènes alors il faut
savoir que dans l'époque récente il y a
eu des disparitions majeures d'organises
alors bien entendu on se focalise plutôt
là sur des animaux de grande
taille la ritine de stellaire le grand
pingouin ou le dodo à Maurice mais c'est
assez typique par exemple si vous prenez
la ritine de stellaire elle a été
découverte et on s'est rendu compte que
cet animal produit isisait une huile
extrêmement
euh je dirais de très haute qualité qui
ne fumait pas et cetera et donc il y a
eu une chasse intensive en plus l' mal
lent pas très agile une chasse intensive
qui a fait qu'en quelques dizaines
d'années et cet espèce a complètement
disparu hein et quelque part là on peut
faire un parallèle avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec l'exploitation des
ressources marines on va dire pour
simplifier les poissons hein où il y a
des
population entière de certaines espèces
de poissons qui sont surpêché qui
disparaissent et cette disparition d'une
espèce particulière va entraîner une
perturbation complète de l'écosystème
marin aux endroits où ces populations
existent et à ce moment-là les
conséquences peuvent être à la fois
surprenantes mais très graves hein donc
par exemple vous avez entendu parler de
ces surpopulations de Médus qui
apparaissent dans certaines m du monde
monde et qui sont lié à la disparition
de prédateurs de Méduse donc les
conséquences de la surpêche vont pas
être seulement disparition d'une
ressource qui est vendue et cetera mais
aussi à Paris modification de
l'écosystème qui va générer donc la la
la prédominance d'un autre organisme
mieux adapté à l'état de au nouvel état
de l'écosystème l'avenir Jean-François
Sylvain comment peut-on protéger cette
biodiversité déjà par l'éducation hein
l'éducation des jeunes et des moins
jeunes
l'éducation la formation la l'apport
d'information aussi au décideurs
décideurs aux citoyens aux
électeurs et aux décideurs politiques
leur faire comprendre un peu ce que je
me je vousi expliqué rapidement et là il
y a des choses qui bougent tout de même
à l'initiative d'ailleurs à l'origine de
la France euh est né ce qu'on appelle
Libes qui est une plateforme
scienceptique qui s'intéresse donc à la
biodiversité au services écosystémique
sur le modèle en gros du GC et qui vise
justement à établir au niveau mondial
d'abord des évaluations de la
biodiversité et des pertes de
biodiversité et de services et ensuite
de progresser pour combler les lacunes
de connaissance et si possible de faire
non pas des lois mais des
recommandations vers les décideurs
mondiaux pour aller vers une gestion
soutenable si on peut dire des
ressources de la biodiversité la
protection de la biodiversité et une
gestion soutenable des ressources issues
de la
biodiversité merci beaucoup pour cet
éclairage Jean-François Sylvain merci
beaucoup ben c'était avec grand plaisir
merci toujours au CNRS N nous restons
sur le thème de la biodiversité mais
cette fois-ci au niveau de l'évolution
des espèces une conférence sur le sujet
se tenait à la Maison de l'Environnement
de CTIN en Yveline et l dioine pour les
images c'est 22000 jeunes c'est
seulement 1 à 2 % du G une réflexion sur
l'évolution des espèces c'est ce que
vient de proposer la Maison de
l'Environnement de Manil etamo lors
d'une rencontre avec Jacques derric
rouau chercheur au CNRS élément majeur
de notre biodiversité les espèces
animales ou végétales ont connu bien des
interprétation à travers les âges des
interprétations d'abord religieuses avec
le créationisme où Dieu est à l'origine
de toute vie sur terre puis plus
scientifique avec les théories de
Lamarque et Darwin qui constateent que
les espèces sont naturelles et qu'elles
évoluent certaines se modifent tellement
qu'elles deviennent même de nouvelles
espèces il y a le lézard des murailles
qui existe que tout le monde connaît en
Europe qui a été importé dans une île de
l'Adriatique suivie par des généticiens
et qui en quelques dizaines d'années
s'est mis à évoluer d'unsectivore il est
devenu herbivore sa mâchoire est
modifiée il y a des
modifications de sa taille de certains
de ces traits si bien qu'avec les
critères actuels avec lesquels on décrit
les lézards ce serait une nouvelle
espèce les espèces ne sont donc pas
immuables elles se transformment
s'adaptent à leur milieu et certaines
disparaissent c'est le principe selon
Darwin de la sélection naturel sur Terre
on ressens aujourd'hui près d'un700000
espèces c'est beaucoup mais elon les
spécialistes il y en aurait près de 100
millions il est aujourd'hui le seul
pisiculteur durable des ivelines et même
d'île-de-fance Emmanuel Coupin nous
présente son élevage de truite et ses
produits qu'il vend en circuit court
rencontre
Emmanuel Coupin est pisiculteur à
Villette près de toiri sa particularité
il est le seul aquaculteur des evvelines
et l'un des très rares en France à
produire de manière durable en
respectant l'environnement chez lui le
calibrage de ces salmonidé s'effectue à
la main sans machine et ces truites
arc-en-ciel ou ses esturgeons reçoivent
un suivi sanitaire régulier d'inggénieur
biologiste côté nourrissage il utilise
des farines animales contrôlé sous forme
de granulé dans son élevage pasogm ni de
médicaments et même si rien ne l'en
empêche il sait que grâce à cela son
produit sera mieux vu par
serette semaine on vaans médicament
c'est un choix purement marketing on a
on peut très bien surcription
vétérinaire avec l'aide de notre
vétérinaire prescrire des médicaments au
poisson comme pour la volaille ou la le
cochon ça me fait plaisir de le faire
parce que je fais pas de pollution dans
l'environnement il y a pas de résidu et
surtout mes clients qui viennent ici
puisque je vends 98 % de ma production
en vente direct à la ferme mes clients
sont contents de voir que j'utilise zéro
médicament un bémol néanmoins ces
farines animales sont issues de poissons
souvent pêché en pleine mer de fait
elles en deviennent coûteuse et peu
écologique Emmanuel Coupin n'a toutefois
pas le choix aujourd'hui les farines
locales d'animaux terrestres qui
pourrait très bien convenir à ces
poissons carnivores sont catalogué comme
dangereuses et selon lui boycotté sans
raison par les circuits de distribution
les circuits les qu ou C circuits
français de distribution parce que ils
tiennent le marché imposent au
producteurs de ne pas utiliser de farine
animoterrestre donc de Pat alors
qu'aujourd'hui on a le droit d'un point
la
réglementation ce qui est complètement
débile d'un point de vue environnemental
on préfère pêcher un poisson milieu de
l'Atlantique ce qui coûte des tonnes
d'équivalents pétrole le ramener en
France pour liophiliser le transformé en
huile et en farine pour nourrir les
poissons plutôt que d'utiliser les
déchets d'abattoir de l'abattoir qui est
à 6 km d'ici sa pisculture produit
chaque année 50 tonnes de poisson la
moitié est vendue vivante pour le
rempoissonnement des rivières et étant
de la région l'autre moitié est consacré
au loisirs pour les pêcheurs qui
l'accueille directement sur son domaine
et à la vente en circuit court via la
boutique où il propose ses produits des
produits artisanaux de qualité qui ne se
veulent pas pour autant plus chers qu'en
grande distribution pour exemple sa tr
fumé il la vend 37 € le kilo en grande
surface pour un produit de même valeur
il faudra presque payer le double
compétitif donc Emmanuel Coupin conçoit
pourtant que son activité est fragile et
même s'il ne compte pas ses heures ses
revenus sont tout juste corrects
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup de
producteurs durables en France il ne se
sent pas valorisé par l'État notamment
une situation qu'il ne comprend pas il
serait raisonnable de penser que un
agriculteur qui fait un du bon travail
qui utilise moins d'un Tran chimique
ourdhui les bi les gont du prod GAM
sontux qui gag le moins leur vie pas
très logique si vous souitez venir
visiter sa pulture fondé en 1896 sachez
qu'elle est gratuite et ouverte en toute
saison 40000 personnes s'y rendent
d'ailleurs chaque
année c'est la fin de votre numéro
d'équilibre mais avant deitter
traditionnel agenda et son nouveau
graphisme le mardi 4 mars vous pourrez
assister à une conférence sur les
conséquences de Fukushima 3 ans après le
tsunami qui a frappé la centrale
nucléaire Jean-Pierre perves spécialiste
de la question répondra à vos
interrogations accompagné d'un bénévole
de la LPO Guille en cours partez à la
découverte des oiseaux au parc des
sources de la Bièvre le dimanche 9 mars
découvr un espace au milieu varié à
quelques uns volet du centre de
Saint-Quentin en iveline enfin venez
découvrir l'aspect changeant du ciel le
monde planétaire et les et les galaxies
grâce à l'association magnitude 78 et
son planétarium samedi 28 mars des
conttes et mythologies vous y seront
également narrés c'est la fin de ce
numéro d'équilibre prochain rendez-vous
le 21 mars ce prochain et d'ici là
n'oubliez pas la terre et notre m
respectonsla
salut